was das will ich noch mal seht
er will etwas glaubt herzlich willkommen
war ihm ein video ich habe heute nach
wirklich sehr sehr lange zeit mal wieder
eine ganz gewisse person dabei ihr könnt
ihr mal raten wer es in den kommentaren
wer bist du nein heute auf jeden fall
dass mein bruder mit dem habe ich vor
einem halben jahr oder so ab und zu mal
videos gemacht oder vor drei monaten
haben wir schon mal das letzte video
zudem aufgenommen und wir haben uns
gedacht kommen machen wir einfach mal
wieder zusammen wie du keine ahnung
warum wir so lange kein video zusammen
gemacht haben auf jeden fall habe ich
eben spontan gedacht ich lade ich wieder
ein und du darfst gerade mal raten was
wir heute machen
ich habe ja damals so vor
das ist schon länger her habe ich zwei
teile von versuch nicht zu lachen
gemacht und die sind wirklich ziemlich
gut bei euch angekommen und ich frage
mich gerade auch so warum habe ich das
nicht noch mal gemacht
genau deswegen habe ich jetzt gedacht
kommen machen wir einfach im dritten
teil
und ich habe mir irgendwann lustiges
video rausgesucht dass ich noch nicht
gesehen habe als ich habe ich noch nicht
gesehen ich hoffe es ist gut und weißt
du was wir sind davon ist ja genau ich
will gar nicht lange gelagert ich hoffe
es gefällt euch und gibt keine
bestrafung gebe es in die kommentare
schreiben wer am meisten lacht und der
verlierer krieg dann irgendeine kasse
bestrafung so das gibt einem separaten
video weil ich habe gerade keine ahnung
das ist ein grad voll spontan entstanden
so bist du bereit
also du darfst nicht lassen dann
schaffst du es nicht zu lachen oder zu
grinsen
also auch nicht grämen
der gesang
schott ag
luft
juli
gut kennt
was das will ich noch mal sehen wie
heftig das baby gegen die wand geflogen
angeboten wird
baby
nein
so leute das was mit dem video-würfel es
dadurch weiter das einkommen seien
schreibt auf jeden fall in die
kommentare
auch wenn es glaube ich schwer ist weil
das war echt wird sich das video als ich
jetzt nicht gedacht ist so witzige
videos gibt weil bei den anderen teilen
war es immer so eine sache so schreibt
genau jetzt die kommentare wäre besser
das interessiert uns wirklich sehr
und der der weniger in den kommentaren
steht darf den anderen genau der
bestrafung könnt ihr auch in die
kommentare schreiben
seid kreativ wir würden auch ein paar
sachen so einfach aber wir können ja
auch irgendwie bestrafung von euch
nehmen und das gibt es dann im separaten
video irgendwann nächste woche glaube
ich und ja mehr will ich nicht sagen ihr
könnt ihr mal berlin.de auf instagram
folgen wenn ihr wollt und das war's
wollten wir natürlich auch schaut rein
wir sehen uns dienstag wieder beim ein
video 18 uhr keine ahnung